autumn is with us in Virginia hi autumn
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Bo hi
what's up so we completely stupid you're
going to speak directly into your phone
I can't hear you I said we've been
completely stupid and made a lot of
really bad decisions can you hear me yes
ma'am so I did the debt calculator on
your website and it said it would take
us 11 years to get out of debt following
your plan and I kind of feel stuck
do you have any advice to speed this up
did that include your house no okay and
how much debt do you have not including
the house we have one hundred and forty
eight thousand eight hundred dollars
okay and what is that on twenty thousand
on credit cards ten of that is in debt
management 16.8 on auto and 102 in
student loans who's the top album huh
who's the doctor I only have 50 for
solving student loans and I don't even
have a degree oh you didn't you didn't
complete what were you studying well I
changed my major million times which is
why I've gone to school like seven years
how much was your husband's degree in
he's a teacher and he had like
40-something Johnson okay which is your
house payment a house painting is six
hundred dollars okay and what's your
household income right now fifty-three
thousand five hundred a year so he's
working full-time and you're working
part-time mmm no I'm not working I I
have a high needs twelve-year-old that I
do homeschool and I have a four month
old yeah you got your hands full
well the the debt snowball calculator
that you used on our website assumes
only that you pay nothing extra
it only assumes that whatever you pay
off goes to the next one when that one
is paid off so if you have a $20 payment
on your smallest debt you increase in
the payment you increase debt number
two's payment by $20 when that pays off
you will pay more than that you should
pay more than that and so you know so
the 10 years is not accurate is my point
so here's the way you do it you do kind
of old-fashioned big number long
division okay we've got a hundred and
forty thousand dollars worth of debt
okay
ten years would be fourteen thousand a
year that's not enough you need to pay
more than fourteen thousand a year so if
you took a hundred and forty and said we
paid twenty a year out of 53 that'd be
doable
that'd be doable you'd be on beans and
rice that's a seven year plan yeah okay
if we sell the car it's a six year plan
well I'm looking to selling my car but
we're upside down it's worth seventh one
of them is was worth 3.5 but we owe
eight and I got a loan also but it's at
65% APR not sure I should do that okay
and the the other car is worth what
about ten and it worried you always
right even we are yeah no you are wait
you said you had 16,000 and car debt and
you laid on each one yeah okay
and so yeah that that one may be gone
you may have to go because here's the
thing every $20,000 you shed and a
$20,000 year rate gives you a year of
your life back and so right now we're at
seven years at 20,000 a year you and I
just making this up sitting here talking
okay yeah and if we if we can get rid of
$20,000 for the debt we would be at six
years if we can increase our income by
$10,000 and
throw it all at the debt your husband
taking on tutoring you working a side
gig that you can work around with your
childcare needs that you have that are
real you know anything you know you
don't work from home stuff you start
selling stuff on eBay I don't care
whatever you want to do but if we
increase our income by ten thousand
dollars a year
now we put thirty thousand dollars a
year on 140 now we're talking a little
over three years that starts to smell a
lot better than ten doesn't it yeah so
you're gonna be on beans and rice budget
you're gonna increase your income and
you're gonna consider selling some stuff
real seriously and not rationalize and
not go oh I have to have this because
dot dot dot knew you don't have to have
nothing you don't have to have nothing
but food shelter clothing and basic
transportation and so that's what you
know because what is the goal here what
are you willing to give up to hit your
goal because it's not what people are
willing to do that causes them to hit
their goals it's what they're willing to
give up to get their goal that causes
them to hit their goals and there's
always a price to be paid so you just
got to look at that and decide I think
if you'll bear down on this get on a
real tight budget both of you increase
your incomes not a ton but at least a
little bit I think you're out of debt in
three and a half to four years you might
be out at three years because you're
probably going to see your some things
change around your house during this
time so good question